[Music]
may 1st
2003 the u.s declares victory in
afghanistan
the bulk of this country today is
permissive
it's secure the taliban had been toppled
only months after 9 11
and there were some 13 000 nato troops
in the country
fast forward nearly 20 years american
soldiers have left the taliban have come
back
and the united nations says civilian
deaths of women and children in
afghanistan
have hit record levels while it's
difficult to map exactly how much
territory the group actually controls
limited data suggests it's more than
half of the country
with the insurgents claiming authority
over major border crossings and
infrastructure
many people both inside and outside the
country have been surprised by the speed
and the scale of the taliban's advances
and by how fragile the afghan
government's authority is looking
it's time to end america's longest war
it's time for american troops to come
home before biden ordered america's
troops to leave
the u.s have been trying to exit for a
while and by the end of next year
our war in afghanistan will be over
the taliban victories meant that u.s
soldiers remained in the country much
longer than
intended and now the foreign troops have
gone and the taliban is steadily taking
over large parts of the country
here's how the insurgent group has
expanded to become stronger than it's
been in 20 years
creating the conditions for potential
chaos as u.s troops leave behind a
country on the brink of civil war
at the beginning of the war america's
campaign in afghanistan reached some
milestones in just a few months
when the u.s led coalition invaded
afghanistan the taliban controlled the
country for five years
after taking power following an
extremely violent civil war
that imposed strict islamic rule on
afghanistan all that changed after 9 11
when president bush set out to punish
the group for harboring al-qaeda
terrorists
the united states military has begun
strikes
against al qaeda terrorist training
camps and military installations of the
taliban regime in afghanistan
bush deployed some 2 500 u.s troops into
the country
causing the taliban to abandon kabul and
soon thereafter kandahar
their main stronghold the taliban were a
broken force at that time
they gave up barely without a fight and
mailed it back into society and
retreated into villages
some taliban commanders actually offered
to surrender in return for amnesty
but the u.s declined that offer and
wanted to
keep fighting them they wanted to stamp
out every last terrorist from
afghanistan
instead the taliban regrouped in
pakistan where they received shelter and
support
with the aim of returning later the
taliban began their resurgence
and by the middle of the decade they had
launched hundreds of suicide attacks and
thousands of bombings
killing hundreds of u.s soldiers
so to counter their renewed presence
obama began deploying more forces in the
region
the united states has conducted an
operation that killed osama bin laden
the leader of al qaeda may 1st 2011
osama
bin laden the man held responsible for
the 9 11 attacks
was killed and around that period the
number of u.s troops in afghanistan hit
a peak of around 100
000
the makers and experts began to question
the effectiveness of that large military
presence
what became clear was that the u.s
counter-insurgency strategy
did not eradicate the taliban in fact
some of the more controversial tactics
that the u.s used in afghanistan such as
night raids and arbitrary detentions and
airstrikes that sometimes kill civilians
created discontent in local communities
and actually help the taliban recruit
more fighters
the taliban's recruitment drive enabled
them to increase in numbers
and gain control of yet more territory
launching near daily attacks against the
us
and afghan forces so with bin laden dead
and facing mounting pressure from
democratic lawmakers in congress
obama announced his plan to withdraw
some 33 000 troops from the region
and transfer power to the afghan
military our mission will change from
combat
to support by 2014
this process of transition will be
complete and the afghan people
will be responsible for their own
security that plan didn't work as
intended
the afghan security forces were plagued
by problems that continued to haunt them
such as corruption which made them an
ineffective fighting force against the
taliban
who continued to fight allegedly armed
and funded by pakistan
the afghan government has acknowledged
problems with effectiveness and
corruption among its security forces
but told the journal that corruption is
decreasing and pakistan's government has
denied backing the taliban
but says it has some limited influence
over the group
this map shows just how much territory
the taliban had taken over in 2017.
the taliban's gradual advances across
the country really began
alarming people in the capital after
nato announced the end of its combat
mission
the taliban scored symbolic victories
such as capturing the city of kunduz
[Applause]
while mapping the taliban's exact
presence has been tricky in such a fluid
situation
some analysts have drawn maps based on
news reports and social media
that outlined the group's territorial
control from 2017.
at the time the afghan military was
already struggling to hold the taliban
back
and trump announced he was sending more
troops the security threats we face in
afghanistan
and the broader region are immense
president trump's announcement fueled
the will to fight among some fighters i
remember speaking to young taliban
fighters
who said that they'd actually considered
giving up the war once the american
troops left
but once president trump said he was
going to send more troops they said
there was no way they want to give up
the fight
around four years later on july 4th 2021
u.s troops finally left bagram
their main base of operations of the
country meanwhile the taliban's
expansion
accelerated we cannot continue the cycle
of extending or expanding our military
presence in afghanistan
as foreign troops pulled out insurgents
took many districts without having to
fight
the group has been trying to show a
friendlier face posting propaganda
videos purporting to show
taliban fighters shaking hands with
afghan soldiers or guarding borders
without disrupting trade
the afghan government didn't respond to
a request for comment on these images
analysts say it's part of a campaign to
legitimize the insurgency
amid negotiations with the afghan
government
while the biden administration says
america's military campaign has
accomplished its objectives
us airstrikes against the taliban are
expected to continue
and america plans to keep monitoring
terrorist threats
people in afghanistan question what the
taliban's plans are
and whether they can coexist with the
afghan government the taliban's gains
raise two main risks for afghanistan one
that the country might split possibly
along sectarian lines which could throw
the country into another bloody civil
war
or that a fundamentalist islamist group
takes power in afghanistan again
which would undermine the whole purpose
of the war which was to eradicate
terrorism risks from the country